Your fight.
The weather is nice to see The fight for the defense of the know-how industry.
Because yes,
we have workers here.
We have workers who have 1 know-how,
who defend it and they must be defended at all,
at all levels,
in the department,
in the region,
at the national level and of course also at the European level.
Competition is now being organized in the European Union.
Because at home,
Amiens, wirpoul,
goodyeur and here the companies that will be relocated in Romania.
We know all too well this reality,
so the competition of loyalists and workers must be fought.
And as we have always done,
you can count on us to fight this competition of loyalists.
The next one to bring us up to date is the enlargement of the European Union.
So today we are talking about Romania,
but tomorrow we will talk about Ukraine and Moldova.
Please note that the minimum wage in Moldova is €50 per month.
€50 per month.
How do you want to say tomorrow that jobs must be preserved here when
you are in an open market where there are salaries of €50 per month.
Well,
you can count on us.
We will be opposed to the enlargement of the European Union,
which will only result in our industry running out.
So let's defend our industrial fabric.